let's have a look at what we've got over
here because we are now finally bringing
angles to a conclusion okay we've done a
lot of different kinds of relationships
there and goes at a point and was on a
straight line and all these parallel
bits I want us to a review and think
about all these in summer okay in flames
a parallel then we have these three
different parent relationships that
we've learnt the names on right and
we've talked out summer today what's the
first kind of pair of angles that we
have Rhea corresponding so I've already
got them on the board corresponding
angles the ones that are how can you
tell me cross one day what makes them
correspond yeah because they're on the
straight line they're on the same side
okay good on the same side they're
facing the same direction do you member
that's the way that I said just look at
which way they're facing and they're the
same way that's corresponding what is
the next one side roommate when
education or now adjacent is a really
important word with angles we revert at
the beginning of this chapter bottom
parallel lives we don't necessarily know
them today so many other people
something else I'm looking for you at
Walton ultimate very good it's a bit
tricky we introduce words so that we can
be precise with our language right but
then you'd get to this problem whether
it's like ah so many words and adjacent
ultimate they sound very similar right
alternate angles equal where are some
all ten angles here can someone tell me
describe you where I could put one for
example which was alternates you aim
that's a bit of a sneaky one yeah okay
so this guy here right this guy's will
be facing the opposite direction and so
on the other side so these guys their
alternate right also angles equal last
one last one the one we just looked at a
second ago yeah criteria very good now
you can see I have left off the end here
as well because these are equal and
equal Molly people they are we use the
word just a min ago
it's very good okay so this is what we
have shown over the last few days okay
now we're going to conclude this last
sentence about okay what we've got here
is a piece of logic okay and I actually
want you to put at the top of your page
right next to your heading like i'm out
to do i want you to see isn't logic if
you've got some statement a and you know
that i'm saying that some say the B's
true each one of these is an air of it
so if lines are parallel if a is true
then B is true I 20 m is equal or
altering Z or any of things right so you
know this you can deduce all you can
conclude this okay now what I'm going to
say it down the bottom here and what I'd
like it all right down together i'm
going to introduce a new word for you
it's not a shoot or clothing brand needs
something else for us the converse is
also true now what is a comment on this
diagram that I've asked you to draw up
here with the statements will help us
write the Commerce is when you take
these statements and you turn them
around you reverse the direction okay
the converse of this what Venus if B
then hey okay you got to be careful in
mathematics as in real life converses
are always true for instance I can say
um you know I have a I have a swear if
the shape is a square then it's also a
rectangle do you agree with that like
ever all of them at 90 degrees so that's
what makes a rectangle rectangle so if
my shape is a square then it's also a
rectangle you can hear my if something
then something else what would the
converse of that statement be rather
than if it's a square then it's also
rectangle what would the commerce but
yeah
so if I reverse these and say it if it's
a rectangle then it's a square obviously
that's not true anymore is it right the
converse often is not the case but here
in parallel lines and we're going to
show in second in parallel lines the
converse is true if you know any one of
these on a pair of parallel lines that
you can say that if you see alternate
angles on a pair of lines and they're
equal that means you conclude their also
parallel if you see Co interior angles
and they look at them they add up to 100
yrs then you can conclude the lines of
pelham okay so here's an example the
right hand side which is a robot and
drive that diagram doesn't have to be
too big but anyone like to borrow rule
of so what we're going to do is we are
going to prove that a pair of like a
parallel and it's not too much to it you
can see here I've got some labels I can
see angle a Q are right you can read its
size there right it's labeled as 75
degrees yeah and I hope it looks roughly
75 degrees I notice that it is also
equal to the same size it's equal to d r
cubed you see that now just like in the
plus few lessons every time you make a
statement you want to back it up with a
reason you want to show why I'm not just
plucking this out of thin air not a
magical statement it's got a reason okay
the reason is on my diagram both are
measured with the sailing at both equal
to 75 degrees okay so they're both the
same size means the end was themselves
article okay now I'm gonna say what
angle pqr angle drq are not just random
angles here right they are related in a
particular way which relationship do
they have out of this set of three it's
one other yeah they alternate fantastic
in the way you can see is they face in
opposite directions right so I'm gonna
say hey they're not just equal they are
alternate angles so if I put those two
pieces of information together that's
this table here alternate angles are
equal so i can conclude this right there
for a B is you remember a symbol for
parallel lines which are two parallel
lines okay abies parallel to CD because
alternate angle I so you can see if you
have a look at our review questions
right our logic is similar but it's
going in the other direction here you
know the lines are parallel so you say
something about the angles here you know
something about the angles so you can
save the lines are parallel does that
make sense okay so here is a good
neighborhood is example to have a look
what kind of relationship do I have
between the two angles that you actually
know something about what kinds of
angles are yes then come to it and you
can see because they're both on the
inside of that pair of parents you see
that backwards see happening great we've
got two rectangles before now when you
have a look at because what I'm
expecting commentary angles to do is to
add up to 180 that's what I'm kind of
expecting do that out 408 what do they
help to say they don't do that they add
a 290 so what I'm going to say is angle
what are our names here am i J plus
angle what do you want to call the other
one how about Bujji
saturday ago oh ji that's the smaller
one in here right it's equal to 110
degrees plus 80 degrees out like we just
saw that's 180 now i'm not that
interested in what's equal to what I'm
interested in is what it's not equal to
its not equal to 180 degrees okay but as
Kim you just measure these are not
random angles these are co interior
angles right em I J and J I our co
interior so what conclusion can I draw
from this right I didn't get the 180
degrees that I was kind of hoping for
right so what does that mean about the
two lanes I've in parallel honey
parallel very good they can't possibly
be parallel because if they were then
they should add up to 180 but the don't
don't right so since this conversing is
happening if I prove that they're not
180 then they're not going to be
parallel yeah yes well um you might have
noticed i didn't put arrows here either
we didn't know right but I proved that
now we actually can put the Arizona
right in this case you know what they
look pretty close to parallel don't
think they look like much but we have
shown by using this logic here that
think they can't possibly be so I'm
going to conclude that right there for
well they call it mm and opie are not
parallel and the reason again has to do
with this right the commentary angles
are not supplementary in lots of
interest so it's the reverse
okay full stop so you can see now this
is kind of a conclusion right we know
lots of different things we can find
answers if we want or given answers we
can apply logic to make conclusions
about what these lines are and how they
related to each other okay